black smoke rising over northeastern
Syria Turkish army tanks and
reinforcements
moved towards the border the Turkish
military says it's captured a number of
villages around the Kurdish control
towns of Tel a beard and Russell hame
it's reported most if not all their
civilian populations have fled the UN
says that more than a hundred thousand
people have been forced from their homes
there are civilian casualties among the
thousands of people fleeing Turkish
artillery shells soldiers and their
Syrian rebel allies Turkey says it's
conducting what it calls an anti-terror
operation to create a safe zone so
Syrian refugees in Turkey can return the
Kurdish Syrian democratic forces or SDF
is putting up fierce resistance Turkey
considers the main Kurdish fighting
force at the SDN was aligned with a
group which has fought the Turkish
government for decades the SDF
fought alongside US forces are highly
effective in defeating ISIL in northern
Syria and the Turkish offensive began
after the u.s. withdrew some of its
forces from the area turkey is NATO's a
second largest military power the bloc's
chief met the Turkish Foreign Minister
in a pre-scheduled visit he called for
restraint but no harsh criticism of the
Turkish government I shared with him my
serious concerns about the ongoing
operation and the risk of further
destabilizing the region escalating
tensions and even more human suffering
while Turkey has legitimate security
concerns expect turkey to act with
restraint Turkey's president remains
defiant the Turkish military is widening
its bombardment of SDF positions along
the border
forcing potentially thousands more
people to flee their homes many of whom
were already internally displaced
victims of the
all in Syria chants trafford al Jazeera
on the turkish-syrian border